[Music]
president biden is taking heat from gop
governors for touting a federal plan for
kova just one day after admitting there
is no federal solution to fight it
south dakota governor christie noam is
among them she is demanding he rescind
those federal mandates and she joins us
now to explain
governor nolan thank you so much for
joining us happy almost new year to you
i love that you're fighting against
mandates but it appears as you are
fighting against mandates biden is
pontificating new ones reporters managed
to shout a question at him as he took
his puppy to the beach there in rehoboth
delaware at his vacation home and asked
him are you up for a mandate for
vaccines if you want to engage in
domestic air travel and he would not
shut down that idea just yet what are
your thoughts on that it's interesting
to me that the president is so bold in
saying that there is no federal solution
yet continuing to impose mandates on the
country and the fact is is that he
doesn't have the authority to put these
mandates in place that's why south
dakota and many other states and
governors and attorney generals have
challenged the federal government on
this authority in court that will be
heard here in january and will win we'll
win because this president has taken
unprecedented action to impose on the
liberties and freedoms of the american
people and sometimes the only ones that
are left to fight are the governors
governor noam what would you ask of the
federal government at this point what
helped the south dakota need what help
do the states need in fighting this
pandemic
you know we really the thing that
they're doing the most
is imposing restrictions and
requirements on us they need to back off
we really need to be able to take care
of our people we've shown that we do it
the best
they've given us resources which is
their role at different times to meet
this pandemic head-on but then let us be
flexible let us do what south dakota did
use personal responsibility to trust our
people to make the best decisions for
themselves and their families that's why
south dakota's got the number one
economy in the country we're getting
through this together
we've got historic revenues and
businesses and people relocating to our
state and it's because people respect to
the freedom that they can get here for
their children and their grandchildren
and know that it will be protected
yeah it's so true and i think that's why
the folks of south dakota love you
governor there and i had the opportunity
to visit with some of those folks
your new grandmother your mom uh we know
the impact of this pandemic on the kids
but it seems like we're prepared to shut
down
schools again can you talk about the
impact mental health and just being
frankly behind the rest of the world
we are but not in south dakota lawrence
because our kids were in their
classrooms you came to south dakota
months ago
and our kids were in school then they've
been in school the entire time and
they're learning and they're they've got
the largest gains and growth in their
education of any other children in this
country because they were interacting
with their teachers they were in the
same social settings that they've always
been in they didn't struggle like the
other kids did with isolation and being
alone like so many during this pandemic
lawrence earlier you said something that
said you wondered if we'd ever get our
civil liberties back in this country
and that's one thing that i have warned
about now since way back in march of
2020 is that when you have a leader
overstep their authority especially in a
time of crisis that that's when you
break this country and we saw so many
leaders do that over the last year and a
half and we've seen that those civil
liberties have been continue to be
degraded and lost by so many people and
why it's so important that they have a
beacon of hope and i think in south
dakota what we've done in the decisions
that we've done and taken and actions
that we've taken here has shown people
that when you do protect those freedoms
and those liberties that it really does
create more opportunities and a better
future for the people that live under
that kind of an environment
governor you know i have a two-year-old
and it struck me the other day that all
she's ever known is covid is mask in
these onerous restrictions and you know
it made me as a mother really averse to
when you look over at new york city and
you have five-year-olds that won't be
allowed to eat in restaurants if they're
not vaccinated it's simply amazing what
do you think as a freedom-loving
governor when you look over at a place
like new york city and you see
five-year-olds forced to eat out in the
cold if they're not vaccinated
yeah i think it should be a choice of
families of parents and grandparents
i've got a little granddaughter named
miss addie or adeline but you know i
look at her face it seems like for hours
and and i'm amazed at how she watches me
the actions that i take she mimics she
learns from she's starting to try to
recreate
some of the facial expressions that all
of us in this family
do with her when we're spending time
together our children are missing out on
that they're missing the opportunity to
learn and to see faces and
build relationships from each other
because of what they're doing in this
isolated state and having masks over
their faces so if families are in a
situation where they need to do
something like that to protect health
and that makes them
really reassured that they're taking the
right action in step then then certainly
do that but i don't think it should be
mandated by the government and when you
give the government that kind of
authority to tell you you have to act in
that way then it's
the precedent that they're setting in
other areas of your life is really
incredible
yeah and to both you and lawrence's
point it'll be hard to reclaim that
personal liberty but
we have to try governor christie gnome
great to talk to you this morning thank
you governor thank you happy new year